I think you're hot until you reject me
and then I think you're ugly
it's a simple equation really easy it's
not harder than that it's not difficult
just don't reject me in front of my
friends why can't women understand that
I just love my job
uh all right hey he's happy to be back
France can make it mandatory for
influencers to label their filtered
Instagram photos to limit the
destructive psychological effects that
they have on viewers so basically let's
say like a chick post a photo but she's
using a filter or something like that
yeah she might have to be like hey by
the way I'm using this filter no I
wonder if she doesn't that's like that's
such a weird thing though because like
some cameras themselves have filters
already built in like in a way oh yeah I
mean that might just be a loophole what
about lighting I know yeah like some
different lenses make you fatter or
skinnier how about just excessive makeup
oh yeah well I mean this is somewhat
similar to like you remember when like
things like fire Festival when like
suddenly all these supermodels had to uh
it changed the scope of like if you're
gonna endorse yeah yeah yeah put the
hashtag ad or hashtag sponsor it could
be I think they should even have that
[__] it feels [__] so dumb that's on
you man the FTC stuff yeah all right
that's this video thank you
you think Shaq uses Icy Hot every day
yeah no I mean like do you need chef to
go all right guys this I'm just a paid
commercial no do you think he's [__]
insured by [__] General's Insurance
you don't think he's got the best [__]
not some cheap ass Insurance you don't
think he has good coverage you can eat
that [__] what is it [__] fat
burger every single day I do feel bad
though because there's all man yeah I
would say like 70 of people are so
[__] stupid that governments probably
have to make it so simple to so they
will harm themselves dude I have a
lawsuit right now because I ordered a
chakarone pizza and he didn't he didn't
deliver it to me
how long ago did you [__] I thought
he was coming with it they didn't say
that he doesn't deliver the pizza he's
the new Papa John that's another example
of pandering to the lowest common
denominator I feel like but the lowest
common is an honor denominator is
oftentimes the majority isn't that sad
that's why I don't vote you know what
I'm saying but I I feel like
I think this is this is to help uh teen
girls yeah because they're the lowest
common denominator
that was happening even with magazines
before the internet came around that's
like the same thing yeah just the new
standard right yeah people are always
going to be more beautiful than you in a
way so I've always been into fitness
right and I would read these magazines
and [__]
up until I was like 23 I literally
thought all these bodybuilders just ate
a lot of steak yeah once I found out it
was steroids I was like oh stupid on me
I don't need a disclaimer on the
magazine I just didn't do enough
research why wouldn't it be tight though
if all the fitness influencers like
disclaimer I'm sucking it in pretty hard
right now suck I'm sucking in once I
release it dude it's it's I'm sucking in
like 21 PSI pressure some of my most
favorite posts are hot girls that are
like oh you know I don't always look
like this I look like this and then they
do a side by side and it's the same [__]
there's no difference
and girls in the comments are like oh
you go girl you're so brave and I'm all
like so relatable you can send it to me
all day and I'll watch it all [__]
don't [__] like just to show it
guilt-free yeah it goes oh look at my
stretch marks I have stretch marks too
and it's like you're still [__] fine
how does the ugly girl feel when they
look at this you're a 9.98 yeah
there's such a double standard with that
man like what the [__] you act like
you're Quasimodo in one one frame and in
the other one you're like this beautiful
is that pandering is that pandering huh
is that pandering yes okay well no it's
it's actually just self-fellation isn't
it like they're sucking their own dick
yeah the double standard is so stupid
it's so strong with like when they have
like like a woman who's like 500 pounds
and everyone's like oh you're so
beautiful but then God forbid a Superman
have a double chin
you know like you'll never see that's
true yeah you know yeah yeah I think
body positivity is only works for women
because guys can't get away with it well
they don't show like the like the actual
making of that video like they'll have
that Nike ad with that big trick right
and then and like they're like just do
it and all that stuff but they're not
showing like the guys who like they're
like hey we got to get a longer wire
lens for this we gotta hey we gotta go
wider on this like they're not showing
all that no no no how it's made a wider
lens we got to go wider we need a 10
millimeter on this [__] do we
have more more lights because everywhere
they walk with shadows it's casting
Shadows everywhere in the more lights
that's what the conversations are saying
so like these IMAX cameras are [__]
heavy you gotta move we gotta move it
back seven feet I've been there I've
heard
like the people aren't cynical enough or
they're not scrutinizing enough so like
everyone takes everything for face value
so when they see everything
is just it is what's presented in front
of them so then they don't even know
that it's not real even the
cushions right yeah
dummy getting slammed his head falls off
and it's don't try this at home yeah I'm
like why you gotta put that fine print
in there like you think people this is
[__] crazy there's people actually
watching that she's trying to slam their
mom's car or they're racing down a
canyon I realized what a dumbass my
uncle was because he was like man we
should not show uh superhero movies and
all these things to kids and I was like
why he goes because when me and my
friends first saw Superman we jumped off
of a house and we all [__] broke our
legs and stuff and I'm like but you guys
are stupid yeah like Superman you guys
were the Crayons stupid like that's
pretty dumb I've watched all those
things I never jumped off a house
that's a parenting figure but in the
movie shouldn't Superman turn to camera
and be like hey kids like don't do it
this is CGI
the cape doesn't work I think it's a
fourth wall that it can afford to be
broken is it worth saving a life yeah
honestly that's that's gonna be the next
20 years probably the movies are gonna
have to have disclaimers in the middle
of it because I'm like you're the idiot
that decided to jump from the house
right if you were Superman you could go
from the curb that's true he doesn't
[__] climb up and then jump that's
blank man you just [__] go like this
yeah I like the science behind that
that's very good very good why did why
did Spider-Man have to jump off a roof
that was pretty visceral
because remember like in the Toby
Spider-Man yeah where he's like he's
like jumping off a [__] roof and [__]
all of every single one of them even the
Andrew Garfield yeah why can't you start
on the street that's a pretty good point
yeah because everyone's gonna see you on
the street if it saves one light just
start on the [__] Street start on the
street yeah he's on the streets
you have to climb to the top yeah it's a
great point because the whole point is
the whole point is just distance anyway
building the building you could just do
that on the street just do it on this
Jackie Chan could do the same [__]
that's why he's not impressive it's not
a cinematic sure but at least it's not
hurting kids do you think kids in China
were dying from trying Jackie Chan
stunts thinking that at the time maybe
it was Hong Kong a kid sliding down the
whole chandelier in a mall
you think about it though you would
never do kids with bird hands everywhere
look at every ball
I think we can all at least uh
understand that like you know yeah the
young young women out there are maybe a
little bit more susceptible right to the
the concept of like the imagery of it
right you got like you got people now
that are just [__] you know botoxing
their lips eyebrow surgery here getting
veneers you know what I mean doing all
these extra things and it's just a lot
more of a and those are the socially
phenomenal people that are online right
just like these absolutely like not
realistic perceptions of beauty and then
like that being the standard for like
Success Through It the sad correlate uh
sad statistic is the correlation with
um the onset of social media and then
the number the rise in suicide in like
teen chicks it's definitely not good
that part is really sad but who are they
doing it for bro
people like blaming men all the time
what the filters yeah yeah yeah it's
true you think it's for us we don't care
we we want to see you wearing a [__]
t-shirt and jeans that's it yeah yeah
cool I don't know especially the shirt's
wet on a trampoline bouncing around the
jeans too I don't need you in a [__]
ball gown all this other stuff all that
shit's for each other it's for each
other dude because Guy standards is like
here girl standards for themselves and
each other's like here guys salivate
more for hot guys online
it's a whole thing with women and and I
think it really sucks if you're in high
school and having social media that
really must be hard because like we were
saying before it's like when we went to
high school the hottest person was just
the hottest person in your school yeah
and now you have to compete against
Jenna Ortega you gotta like compete
against people that are not even in your
school like these are the coolest people
you're looking at the top one percent
yeah with filters with [__] plastic
surgery with great photography yeah but
guys are easy
[Laughter]
equation really easy it's not harder
than that it's not difficult so don't
reject me in front of my friends why
can't women understand that yeah they
just can't you just have to force it I
guess guys will lower their standard to
any [__] women that'll give them
attention or a [__] like it's it's a
hundred thousand percent accurate
just an accurate State hundred thousand
percent
you can't beat those numbers have you
ever seen that Instagram uh account
called celeb face
all they do is they post pictures at
Celebrities post and they find the
originals and they just show how much
they're different whoa because it's
edited by the VR team yeah it's freaking
amazing yeah and it really shows you how
far they go yeah no matter what is
Gwyneth Paltrow
and
uh I was looking at pictures of her in
court in court oh harsh overhead
lighting and I'm like damn you are of
advertising for goop right now
wait the one where she's holding like a
coffee mug and she she looks like she
doesn't give a [__] yeah yeah exactly
Amber Heard was like that too that's
true she's still hot in court yeah
you're like if you could be hot in court
you're [__] hot yeah you're like what
the [__] put him on trial to see yeah
and you're losing the trial and you're
still fine in court it's a funny status
if you're hot in court you're not losing
the truck no no maybe that's why there's
so much Court porn
is there
[Laughter]
that's a weird Niche dude everyone at
the same time what dude that's why he's
on YouTube
that's how you do it take a note Nick
take some notes okay write it down Nick
more porn you want to be a big
influencer like a rest of us
you want to make it to this town
[Music]
foreign